Olá você já parou para pensar como os
primeiros momentos após acordar podem
ditar o seu bem-estar pro resto do dia
aqui o Dr aland Dutra médico há mais de
25 anos e hoje eu vou compartilhar dicas
sobre como indicar uma rotina matinal
que não apenas se encaixe na sua agenda
apertada mas que realmente melhore sua
energia ajude no emagrecimento no sono
reparador na memória e no humor ao longo
do dia pessoal são apenas 30 minutos de
manhã ou até menos mas eu entendo a vida
moderna não é fácil muitos de vocês
acordam muito cedo preparam as crianças
pra escola enfrentam o trânsito ou
transporte público São tantos desafios
logo cedo então você pode estar pensando
mas doutor eu não tenho tempo para nada
de manhã eu estou aqui para lhe mostrar
que pequenas mudanças podem fazer uma
grande diferença não se preocupe as
mudanças que eu vou sugerir são simples
e baratas nada revolucionário nada de
mudar radicalmente a sua vida de uma
hora para outra a ideia começar pequeno
talvez acordando apenas meia hora mais
cedo e gradualmente incorporar hábitos
que vão energizar o seu dia e ter um
impacto enorme na sua saúde pessoal a
qualidade do nosso sono é a base para
termos um dia produtivo e uma vida
saudável e sim conquistar uma noite de
sono reparadora pode ser um Desafio em
meio ao corre corre diário e aos hábitos
que muitas vezes adquirimos sem perceber
por isso eu quero compartilhar com vocês
algumas práticas simples que podem
transformar a forma como você termina o
dia e consequentemente como começa o dia
seguinte vamos começar falando sobre
exercícios físicos atividades intensas
são excelentes pra saúde mas quando
feitas muito tarde podem manter o nosso
corpo em um estado de alerta isso vai
dificultar o relaxamento necessário para
você pegar no sono um sono adequado
profundo o ideal então é terminar
qualquer exercício intenso pelo menos 4
horas antes de ir pra cama pessoal estou
falando de exercício intenso um
alongamento antes de dormir não vai
atrapalhar ok
isso dá ao nosso corpo o tempo
necessário para desacelerar e se
preparar para o descanso agora sobre
alimentação comer tarde da noite é outro
hábito que pode prejudicar a qualidade
do nosso
sono mesmo que algumas pessoas consigam
dormir logo após uma refeição isso não
significa que o sono seja de qualidade o
corpo precisa de tempo para digerir
antes de relaxar totalmente por isso o
ideal é que façamos nossa última
refeição pelo menos 4 horas antes de
dormir permitindo que o processo de gest
cório não interfira no nosso descanso e
quanto à luz especialmente a luz azul
emitida por telas de celulares tablets
computadores e até luzes LED Ela é uma
grande inimiga do Sono a exposição a
essa luz antes de dormir pode suprimir a
produção de melatonina o hormônio que
nos ajuda a dormir portanto recomendo
desligar todos os dispositivos
eletrônicos pelo menos 2 horas antes de
ir para a cama em vez de olhar para uma
tela que tal ler um livro conversar com
sua família ou participar de qualquer
outra atividade relaxante que ajude a
tranquilizar sua mente Além disso
estabelecer e manter um horário regular
para dormir ajuda muito mesmo se você se
propõe a deitar às 10 da noite faça
disso um hábito nosso corpo adora
rotinas e acostumá-lo a um horário fixo
para o sono pode melhorar
significativamente a qualidade desse
sono pessoal agora vamos para a rotina
matinal após uma boa noite de sono ao
despertar o nosso corpo já começa a se
preparar para o novo dia de uma maneira
muito interessante a temperatura
corporal aumenta e com ela o nível do
hormônio cortisol muitas vezes chamado
de hormônio do estresse mas é importante
lembrar que o cortisol tem várias
funções essenciais como melhorar nosso
sistema de defesa imune o imunológico
acelerar o metabolismo e aumentar a
nossa capacidade de concentração agora o
ideal é que o cortisol atinja o seu pico
logo de manhã para ajudar a preparar
nosso corpo e mente para o dia que se
inicia
um fator que influencia diretamente
nesse pico de cortisol é a exposição à
luz solar que deve acontecer até no
máximo 40 minutos depois que você
acordar curiosamente possuímos um
conjunto de células no olho chamadas
células
melanopsin que são especialmente
sensíveis à luz brilhante da manhã elas
ajudam a sinalizar pro cérebro que é
hora de acordar energizando todo o corpo
e ajustando nosso relógio biológico para
uma boa noite de sono subsequente isso
mesmo se você se expor a luz logo que
você acorda ajuda na sua noite de sono
seguinte e você deve repetir essa rotina
mesmo que o dia esteja nublado Ok então
pense que você conseguiu acordar 30
minutos mais cedo do que o habitual e
este é o momento ideal para regular o
seu ciclo circ cade ano com a exposição
ao sol sem janelas sem vidros óculos de
sol ou de grau entre você a luz solar
aproveite e tente expor o máximo
possível de sua pele ao sol para também
aumentar a sua vitamina D durante esse
tempo ao sol aproveite para fazer
alongamento simples alongue o pescoço os
braços as pernas movimentos básicos que
ajudam a acordar seu corpo física e
mentalmente
após se alongar divida os 10 minutos e
incorpore também exercício de respiração
profunda
inspire expire lentamente o que pode
ajudar a calmar a mente e preparar você
para as tarefas do dia lembre-se começar
o dia em um estado de calma e controle é
muito importante o segundo passo da
manhã é um pouco complicado para alguns
mas preciso compartilhar mesmo assim
tomar um banho frio embora possa parecer
desafiador para muitos tomar um banho
frio por até 3 minutos no máximo pode
fazer Maravilhas o choque térmico ajuda
a aumentar a temperatura corporal e
estimula a produção de cortisol além de
outros hormônios como testosterona e
serotonina o banho frio também tem um
efeito revigorante aumentando a sua
energia e alerta para enfrentar o dia se
a ideia de um banho com completamente
frio é muito para você Experimente
começar com uma temperatura morna e
gradualmente ir reduzindo e ajustando
para mais frio lembre-se que é um banho
frio rápido de 1 a 3 minutos no máximo
após o banho frio é essencial cuidar da
sua higiene oral usar um raspador de
língua ajuda a remover bactérias e
resíduos que podem causar problemas como
disbiose intestinal e candidíase oral
Este é um passo pequeno mas poderoso
para começar o dia com o pé direito e
claro a hidratação não pode ser
esquecida beber água é fundamental após
Horas de Sono comece seu dia consumindo
pelo menos 500 ml de água para reidratar
o corpo e prepará-lo para o dia que se
inicia Depois de estar hidratado você
vai cuidar do café da manhã e aqui vai
uma dica ao invés de correr para a
cafeína Vamos focar um café da manhã
nutritivo que sustente e dê energias
para as primeiras horas do seu dia deixa
a cafeína para tomar de preferência uma
a duas horas após acordar pessoal eu sei
que muitos de vocês não TM tempo para
preparar um grande café da manhã ou que
precisam de algo prático Por estarem
sempre correndo contra o tempo no
entanto é fundamental se organizar para
que essa refeição seja eficiente e
nutritiva já que um café da manhã ideal
não inclui opções rápidas e comuns como
pães salgados ou cereais matinais o foco
deve ser iniciar o dia com proteínas
gorduras saudáveis e fibras para
garantir energia sustentada e evitar o
aumento da Fome durante o dia o que pode
resultar em mais Picos de glicose Picos
glicêmicos levando com tempo ao ganho de
peso pré diabetes resistência insulina e
em alguns casos até diabetes se a
primeira coisa que você come no seu dia
é algo cheio de Açúcar o carboidrato
refinado Logo logo o seu corpo vai pedir
mais açúcar você terá mais fome e terá
um montanha russa de Picos de glicose no
sangue o que não é nada saudável Eu
recomendo fortemente evitar açúcares e
doces logo cedo assim como reduzir o
consumo de carboidratos se for
incluir carboidratos na sua manhã opte
por carboidratos complexos é o caso de
batata doce mandioca inhame que devem
ser consumidos por último na refeição
uma estratégia interessante é começar
com as proteínas como ovos mexidos
omeletes ou um frango desfiado que você
pode preparar de forma antecipada e
deixar na geladeira Isso facilita muito
a sua rotina permitindo que você apenas
aqueça o mesmo cuma frio se você
preferir complemente com fibras
adicionando frutas menos doce como
abacate morango amora mirtilo pêssego
melão maçã e kiwii que são excelentes
para começar o dia agora para aqueles
que não abrem mão de algo quentinho pela
manhã uma excelente opção é o leite
Dourado feito com leite de coco e
especiarias como cúrcuma gengibre canela
que além de aquecer oferecem benefícios
antiinflamatórios para os que preferem
algo mais refrescante um shot matinal de
limão com própolis pode ser revigorante
e muito benéfico pra saúde pessoal a
importância de incluir gordura saudáveis
e fibras no seu desjejum também não pode
ser subestimada utilize azeite de oliva
óleo de coco ou inclua uma porção de
abacate E por que não começar o dia com
uma salada ou vegetais quem diz que não
podemos comer vegetais ou um bife por
exemplo no café da manhã romper com
conceito tradicional de café pode ser
extremamente benéfico para sua saúde eu
tenho uma paciente que prepara frango
desfiado ou carne moída com purê de
abóbora cabotiá tudo bem temperado com
ervas naturais e ela deixa na geladeira
para consumir no dia seguinte no
desjejum com ovos e abacate lembre-se
que você também pode e deve adicionar
fibras importantes como linhaça chia
sementes de abóbora gergelim e noz pode
ser em um iogurte natural consumido com
as frutas que Eu mencionei vou resumir
as dicas para facilitar para garantir
que você tem um milagre matinal que
realmente transforme seu dia comece com
uma boa preparação na noite anterior
Isso inclui dormir sempre no mesmo
horário desligar as telas de computador
C cular e outras telas pelo menos 2
horas antes de dormir evitar refeições
pesadas e exercícios intensos perto da
hora de deitar ao acordar exponha-se ao
sol por pelo menos 10 minutos enquanto
absorve o sol aproveite para fazer
alongamentos praticar meditação ou
exercício de respiração profunda
cultivando assim pensamentos bons
afirmações positivas após esse momento
ao sol tome seu banho se possível um
banho frio de até 3 minutos que é muito
revigorante mas lembre-se de que cada
pequeno passo já é um progresso durante
ou após o banho Faça também uma higiene
da língua incluindo o uso de um raspador
específico para a língua hidratação é o
próximo passo essencial beba água pura
como primeira ingestão do dia para
ativar ou reativar o seu sistema interno
após o longo período de jejum noturno
depois prepare um café da manhã
nutritivo dando prioridade a alimentos
ricos em proteínas gorduras saudáveis e
fibras se for incluir carboidratos opte
pelos complexos deixe-os por último na
refeição para manter a saciedade e os
níveis de energia estáveis evite
consumir açúcares carboidratos refinados
especialmente nas primeiras horas do dia
também É aconselhável adiar o consumo de
café preto para pelo menos uma ou duas
horas após acordar permitindo que o seu
corpo desperte mais naturalmente e por
fim mas igualmente importante comece o
dia com atitudes positivas cumprimente
com carinho os membros da sua família
distribua elogios e não subestime o
poder de um abraço até mesmo de um beijo
essas pequenas ações não apenas melhora
o seu dia mas também o das pessoas ao
seu redor se você mora sozinho mantenha
uma postura otimista faça uma
autoavaliação positiva para começar o
dia com pé direito compartilhe os
[Música]
vídeos muito obrigado pela sua atenção
um grande abraço bej seu coração Você é
fera